the river ganges in haridwar india is a  holy pilgrimage site for millions of  hindus and is visited by hundreds of  thousands of people each year  it's also home to the largest  hand-written family tree in the world  [Music]  for centuries a sect of priests known as  pundits have updated and maintained  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  each of the records are sorted by family  lineage and include reports of births  deaths and other important events many  of which span hundreds of years  [Music]  while talks are underway to digitize  these records the pundits take great  care to preserve each delicate page in  hopes of maintaining family histories  for generations to come  [Music]  okay  [Music]  you